blanche neige revient en majesté dans
les jardins de l'orangerie jusqu'à
vendredi
ce ballet créé par angelin prejlocaj en
2008 connu un succès international
immédiat et obtient en 2009 le globe de
cristal trailer à la dramaturgie très
riche
l'oeuvre est la plus populaire des 49
créations de chorégraphes
c'est une nouvelle façon d'aborder la
danse c'est à dire de vraiment raconté
par le corps par les mouvements une
histoire à raconter chaque événement
parce que tout y est
j'essayais justement de faire une oeuvre
populaire et de mettre tout mon exigence
d que dans l'écriture chorégraphique
pour rester au niveau quand même le plus
haut par la danse sans descendre à
lhassa et tout en allant quand même vers
quelque chose qui va aussi bien en
chanter une petite fille de 7 ans que
que quelqu un qu un homme de 70 ans qui
a découvert sa voie là
cette parenthèse féerique réunis les 24
danseurs de la compagnie d'angelin
preljocaj
créé en 1985 l'adaptation de l'oeuvre
est resté fidèle à la version du conte
des frères grimm de 1812 un compte
encore très contemporain par ces
thématiques autour de l'image et de la
vieillesse
j'ai trouvé que blanche neige était un
compte absolument moderne parce que de
nos jours avec les projets de les
progrès de l'art de la science de la
médecine la diététique la cosmétique
aussi ça amène de cette condition cette
situation qui peut faire naître un
problème de 2,2
de conflit autour de la séduction je
crois qu'on est dans l'air un peu du
complexe de blanche-neige presse comme
on dit qu'il ya le complexe de dix
combats notre époque peut-être génère le
complexe de blanche neige par le fait
que les femmes sont plus libres plus
belle et que leur fille finalement
entrent en conflit de séduction avec
elle par rapport à des prétendants
blanche-neige partir à poursuivre sa
tournée en corée du sud fin juin et pour
les amateurs des chorégraphies d'angelin
preljocaj
le ballet roméo et juliette sera
représenté au théâtre de chaillot fin
décembre à paris